un succès foudroyant cette année les
spectacles burlesques de travestis ce
soir 80 rue des martyrs chez michou bush
parle il ya du monde l'art au chanteur
oui il y en a un peu ce que je ressens
la france garde
je suis cabaret tier depuis 14 ans vous
appelez cathy michel j'ai 39 ans et
steve omischl ou c'est moi michaud
jeunes du rock
quel est votre profession teinturier
alors non pas s'auto lui ces prénoms
bissière h 39 ans comment s'est passé
l'évolution de votre établissement car
au départ c'était un restaurant et
maintenant c'est un
boîte de nuit à café qu'on ne sait pas
une boîte de nuit ça tout petit
spectacle qu'on a monté entre trois bons
copains
voyez un jour si vous au départ cela
canular on n'a jamais cru à la réussite
comme ça c'est passé voilà c'est que mon
bateau se rende s'amuse plus y'a plus
rien de drôle les gens pour faire venir
les jarres montmatre maintenant ils
voudraient quelque chose d'assez drôle
piquant les je pense qu'on y est réussi
alors avec jeudi avec de beaux mais avec
mon copain eugène qui est nature et
lucien qui est barman qui est un vieux
copain mois copain de régiment même et
on a monté ce qui ce fait un genre de
parodie vous voyez sur les sur des
artistes qu'on aime
dans l'iso show de jeu d'entrée leur
aide et sans qu'il sache avec amour à
les douceurs
ou joli bébé requin je vais te dévorer
le tanneur
[Musique]
vous imitez que les femmes oui j'avoue
que j'ai vite pour l'instant oui mais
déjà c'est beaucoup plus amusant
[Musique]
en playback se disent que vous chantez
vous faites semblant de chanter je me
sentais bien que mis mon nom me monde
est étonné tr/min et vous limitez qui
déshabillent et moi
[Musique]
élisez moi
on divisait - a
soyez là
agissez
[Applaudissements]
des amis et vous
[Musique]
déshabillez vous
c'est à dire que ces libertins on voit
pas très bien comment vous pouvez
arriver à retrouver sa corpulence will
we met d'accord mais côté burlesque mais
une chose dont vous êtes travesti week
investi oui mais est-ce qui vous est pas
venu à l'idée d'un jour il ya la
surprise à vos clients il y avait là je
crois vos amis il ya de quoi rire et à
le garagiste et nous est jamais venu à
l'idée
ce2 et puis aussi a déjà connu quelques
fois de les servir habillé en femme
trahie hors japon et qui vous habille
curiae non c'est non c'est betty femme
quel numéro faites-vous qui imite et
vous ne la mousse corps et rené pasteur
et
[Musique]
je vais vous faire
shenzhen
tu es
[Musique]
mc
shi
m
[Musique]
peut-on parler d'une véritable
profession non vous ne touchez pas de
cachet non mais ce que quelquefois
l'idée ne viendrait pas de savoir
chanter vraiment faire numéro par vous
même je chante
vous avez un grand projet une grande
ambition une chaîne de te tuer aurait
tout numéro que j'aime beaucoup
pauline carton quête unamic vraiment
j'adore suis moi que tu viens sans
sourciller allons gazouiller sous les
palétuviers je peux me saouler pas je
peux me saouler les palais du bio rose
et on nous oublie pas que prouve à
souhait les téléphones ou sous l'évier